The value of art today is a slippery
topic.
Take a canvas out of the pump,
have an art gallery without the price
tag and many people would find it
difficult to guess the price of the
piece,
like when banksy set up a street stand
for his art and almost no one noticed.
Let's see if you can do better.
Try to guess how much these pieces of
art
cost.
It wasn't always this difficult before
the 20th century,
especially in Europe.
It was a more objective measure of art.
There was the hierarchy of genres
codified by the European Academy of arts
with the highest genre holding more
prestige and cultural value,
and in general,
a great artist was a master craftsman
and intellectual capable of capturing
reality and recreating history,
and as you look up and down the
hierarchy,
it's clear that there's value given to
what is difficult faces,
which are the hardest to paint our
weighted.
The highest unmoving simple objects are
the lowest and excluding moral waiting.
I think this is a pretty intuitive
valuation.
What is difficult is valuable.
All of this nicely agreed upon.
Valuation was ruined by the dark room.
Now known as the camera Obscura,
the name comes from an optical
phenomenon where you can project an
image onto a back wall through a
Pinhole,
but the image is very dim,
so you have to keep the room almost
totally dark to see it and pretty
quickly many began realizing that with
film,
that is photosensitive.
They could use the dark room to capture
moments forever.
It all happened quickly.
The first pictures were taken in the
early 19th century,
and by the end of that century,
the Eastman Kodak Company was selling
cameras with film for $1.
This shook the very ground beneath
artists feet.
Remember just before this,
before photographs,
art was the only way of capturing a
moment.
If you wanted to remember a view,
share some technical idea or even
commemorate your kingly face for
posterity,
you'd need skill with a quill or the
money to buy it,
but not anymore.
Reality can be claimed by anybody in a
bright flash that painted a moment with
photon perfect accuracy with a higher
order of detailed than most painters
could dream up.
Take a second.
What do you do as an artist?
What do you do when portraits,
life studies,
even landscapes can be memorialized
without dragging out a pot of paint or
an easel that can be done cheaper and
faster by any untrained buffoon who's
got a buck?
What do you do?
Well,
for artists in the 20th century,
a wide scattering occurred with a burst
of art that mostly avoided realism,
cubism,
fauvism,
post-impressionism,
modernism,
surrealism.
There was tons of abstraction and work
to define light,
to copy it.
Looking back,
it's not surprising why when photography
burst into our hands,
traditional meaning was lost for a lot
of artists and found again with
completely different routes.
A lot of modern art is challenging the
very idea of objective value and meaning
art.
Today,
modern art doesn't carry an objective or
generally agreed upon value because they
lost that along time ago.
Instead,
the value of art is entirely subjective.
Whatever you think that piece is worth
is what it's worth,
and this means that for many who strike
up the intuitive and historical position
that art value should be related to
difficulty.
There's a paradigm sized gap between
them and the artist's prices and we
would do well to observe the cultural
shift here in art and other places where
technology has made something easy or
automated because the birth of the dark
room and the way it shaped art history
gives us insights into how our modern
world and definitions of value might
react to the upending of human
difficulty.
I want to be a force for real good.
In other words,
I know that there are bad forces forces
that bring suffering to others and
misery to the world,
but I want to be the opposite force.
I want to be the force which is truly
for good.
Thanks for watching that video.
If you liked it,
you guys know how to support it.
All the links are down below.
If you like the music,
please go check out Joe Pecoraro and
Mecca 83 incredible producers.
As I'm sure you heard.
Finally got some exciting news.
I'm releasing a new line of experimental
artist.
It's actually only one piece of art.
Just one of one.
I think you'll like it.